Signing credit card receipts or one of
those antiquated systems of record
keeping that use to make more sense,
but now through preservation of only the
tradition and not the purpose has lost
most of its meaning and desperately
needs to be replaced.
Kind of like that collection of vhs
tapes you still have from the 90s even
though you no longer have a vhs player
to understand this,
let's go back to the credit card
receipt.
Glory days.
Actually we have to rewind a little bit
before that and talk about credit.
As a rule,
people hate spending money but they love
getting stuff.
People will spend more if they don't
have to spend now but can get stuff now
and businesses love getting more money
even if they have get it later.
This is where the idea of a tab or
credit comes from.
At first lines of credit,
we're limited in where they can be used.
Sometimes I borrow would give you a coin
or token is proof of you being a loyal
customer and lets you build a tab and
their bar or a gas station would give
you a paper card as credit to a few
exclusive stores within the area and it
built in.
I didn't do protection existed because
in most of these places everyone in the
town knew everybody so they would know
if the card wasn't held by the right
person,
but as they need for a more universal
credit system came about,
credit card issuers had to find some way
of securing their cars to protect
against fraud.
After all,
if you're from Ohio and someone uses
your card in New York,
how's the merchant to no,
it isn't you.
So this is where the signature on the
back of your card comes in.
Merchant has you sign your credit card
receipt and is supposed to check it to
signatures matched to prove it is really
you.
Now,
even when that system kind of made
sense,
it had all sorts of flaws in comparing
signatures properly,
takes too much time with the average
clerk isn't a signature expert and
because your signature is right on the
back of the card,
any industrious thief could just
practice your signature for a day before
actually going out on a spending spree.
But this system makes even less sense
now because when's the last time anyone
actually compared your signatures like
that?
So why do we still have to sign?
It all has to do with blame.
If merchants don't have you signed and
you decide that you wanted to speak to
charge,
the credit card company will make the
merchant reimburse it.
But if they did make you sign,
they can say they used reasonable fraud
prevention methods to verify that it was
you.
In that case,
either you or the credit card company,
it would have to pay.
But let's not get lost in business
buzzwords here.
It's important to note that what
everyone considers to be reasonable
fraud prevention is not reasonable at
all because they never checked.
If your signature matches anything.
Let me give you an analogy.
Imagine bars were tired of the time it
takes to individually check everyone's
Id that the government tells them they
still need to check if everyone's 21
because the law says so.
So in efforts of reasonable age
identification,
they ask everyone,
are you 21 and if they say yes,
they can drink,
this system would help the barb prove
that they were trying to stop underage
drinking,
but the actual results would be the
equivalent of having no check it all.
And that's my point.
Your credit card signature is equivalent
to no signature at all because it will
never stop anyone from using your credit
card.
So what do we do about it?
Well,
the good news is technology is making
fraud protection easier and better than
ever.
And Europe,
they rolled out a chip and pin system,
which requires a pin every time you try
to buy something.
This is at least as fast as signing a
receipt and actually has some real
security in it.
But in America,
although we've adopted the chip cards,
we're still using our signature system.
Why you ask one credit card company,
explain the kiss.
If you can possibly ignore the dripping
condescension in the statement.
What it boils down to is that you're
only going to get a credit card with
actual security when you want it.
And for that to happen,
people everywhere need to realize that
the story of the signature is a lie.
It doesn't protect you and worse,
it breeds a false sense of security in a
system that needed to be replaced
decades ago.